INTERNATIONAL FLIGHTS IN AND OUT
OF WUHAN PROVINCE.
WE WILL HAVE A REPORT COMING UP
TONIGHT.
FIRST, WE JUST WITNESSED MORE
BLATANT, MALICIOUS DECEPTION,
SMEARS, LIES, BESMIRCHED MEN,
FROM THE MOB AND THE MEDIA.
LOOK AT THIS ARTICLE IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
IT IS ENTITLED "A BELOVED BAR
OWNER WAS SKEPTICAL ABOUT THE
VIRUS, THEN TOOK A CRUISE."
THIS WOMAN’S NAME IS -- PRETTY
MUCH ALL BUT ACCUSED YOURS TRULY
OF MURDER.
THE STORY FEATURED A WELL-LIKED
NEW YORK BAR OWNERS -- HIS NAME
WAS JOE JOYCE.
APPARENTLY AN AVID FAN OF
FOX NEWS.
FIRST, I WANT TO STOP.
I WANT TO EXTEND MY SIP OF THE
TWO’S FRIENDS.
SO WELL-LIKED APPARENTLY, HIS
FAMILY, HIS LOVED ONES AND
MR. JOYCE APPARENTLY WAS A VERY
SPECIAL PERSON.
I’M SURE THIS IS VERY HARD ON
ALL OF THEM.
AND SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE THAT
ARE DEALING WITH WHAT THE
PRESIDENT DEALS WITH -- WHAT THE
PRESIDENT CALLS AN INVISIBLE
ENEMY.
THE TIMES CLAIMS THAT SOMETHING
I SAID IN EARLY MARCH, MARCH 9TH
TO BE EXACT, JOYCE DECIDED IT
WOULD BE OKAY TO TAKE A CRUISE
TO SPAIN.
NOW, THEY CLAIM HE ULTIMATELY
CONTRACTED CORONAVIRUS, DIDN’T
QUITE TIE TO THE CRUISE
COMPLETELY AND SADLY HE PASSED
AWAY.
NOW, THIS IS WHERE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SLANDER
BEGINS.
IN ORDER TO SMEAR YOURS TRULY,
THEY LITERALLY -- THIS WOMAN
EXPLOITED AMMAN’S’ TRAGIC DEATH.
SHE WILLINGLY, MALICIOUSLY,
PURPOSEFULLY TOOK SOMETHING I
SAID COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTEXT
AND AS PROVEN BY ALL MY PAST
STATEMENTS THAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WAS VERY
WELL AWARE OF AND IT GETS WORSE.
THERE WERE REMARKS THAT SHE
USED, THEY WERE FROM
MARCH THE 9TH.
TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT.
-- THOSE OF THE REMARKS THAT
SHE REFERRED TO IN HER
SLANDEROUS PEACE.
THAT IS SLANDER.
THAT IS LIBEL.
FORGET ABOUT ME AND ALL OF THIS.
POLITICIZING A TRAGEDY, THIS
"NEW YORK TIMES" SO-CALLED
WRITER REPORTER, WHATEVER SHE
IS, HAS ADDED TO THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING OF A FAMILY THAT
DESERVES BETTER.
THIS WAS ALL DONE TO VILIFY THIS
PROGRAM IN THIS CHANNEL.
AND THAT’S NOT ALL.
AS REPORTER JOEL POLLICK OF
BREITBART.COM AND THE MULTIPLE
OTHER OUTLETS, TO THEIR CREDIT,
POINTED OUT, THAT WHEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" GOT CAUGHT
SPREADING THE LIGHT -- IN OTHER
WORDS, WIPES, THEY ALREADY TOOK
THE CRUISE.
WE MESSED THAT UP.
WHAT THEY DID, THEY DIDN’T MAKE
A CORRECTION, THEY DIDN’T
HIGHLIGHTED CHANGE, THEY JUST
TRY TO SNEAK IT IN, A STEALTH
EDIT IN THE ARTICLE.
IN OTHER WORDS, TO INCLUDE A
MORE ACCURATE TIMELINE
CONSIDERING THEY BOTCHED AT THE
FIRST TIME.
AND BY THE WAY, THAT COMPLETELY
CONTRADICTED THE ENTIRE THESIS
OF THE ARTICLE.
A REAL JOURNALIST, REAL
NEWSPAPER WOULD ADMIT THAT THEY
WERE ELOPED WRONG, ISSUE A CORRE
IN AN INTERESTING WAY THERE
STOPPED AT IT IS NOTHING BUT AN
ADMISSION OF THEIR GUILT AND AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW THEY TRY TO COVER
UP THEIR SMEAR, THEIR SLANDER,
THEIR LIVES AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
BELAFONTE, SHE’S A HACK.
SHE WORKS FOR A DISGRACEFUL
ORGANIZATION, THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT LIED RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
AND KAVANAUGH, KAVANAUGH, THE
SAME PEOPLE THAT PROTECTED
CLINTON, THE PROTECTED CALL ME,
THE DEEP STATE.
ANNETTE NEVER INVESTIGATED THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OUR CORRUPTION IN
HISTORY, THEY WERE TOO BUSY
SPREADING CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
AND MORE HOAXES.
AND BY THE WAY, GET ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF BEYOND JOURNALIST
MALFEASANCE HERE, THEY’RE
CULPABLE.
AND QUIETLY EDITING THE CONTACT
WHEN THEY’RE CAUGHT RED-HANDED.
BY THE WAY, THAT’S NOT WHERE THE
STORY IS.
IT GETS WORSE FOR THEM.
ON FEBRUARY 20, 3 DAYS BEFORE
MR. JOYCE DECIDED TO GO ON THE
CRUISE, THE SAME HACK
ATTRACTIVELY FOR HIS DEATH, ELLA
FONTE, SHE TWEETED THIS.
"I FUNDAMENTALLY DON’T
UNDERSTAND THE PANIC.
INCIDENCE OF THE DISEASE IS
DECLINING IN CHINA."
BY THE WAY, THE VIRUS IS NOT
DEADLY, VAST MAJORITY OF CASES.
PRODUCTION AND SO ON WILL SLOW
DOWN AND WILL OBVIOUSLY
REBOUND."
OKAY.
THAT IS THE TYPE OF BEHAVIOR --
BY THE WAY, SAME
"NEW YORK TIMES" FIVE OR SIX
DAYS AFTER THE PRESIDENT BUT THE
TRAVEL BAN IN EFFECT, THAT WOULD
BE THE SAME "NEW YORK TIMES"
THAT SAID WHO SAYS IT’S NOT SAFE
TO TRAVEL TO CHINA?
BAD ADVICE THEY ARE TOO.
THIS IS THE KIND OF RAMPANT
HYPOCRISY, NEGLIGENT BEHAVIOR
THAT IS SO WIDESPREAD.
THIS IS THE 99% OF THE MOB IN
THE MEDIA AND I CALL THEM A MOB
FOR REASON.
THEY ARE NOTHING BUT STATE-RUN
PRINT, STATE-RUN TV.
THEY ARE THE ALLIES OF ALL
THINGS RADICAL DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST AND EXTREMIST.
TONIGHT THEIR PATTERN OF
MISCONDUCT CAN BE BROKEN DOWN
INTO THREE CATEGORIES.
LET’S LOOK AT ONE.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PLAYED
DOWN, THEY IGNORE THE VIRUS.
NUMBER TWO, THEY POLITICIZE THE
VIRUS.
REMEMBER?
THEY USED TO CALL THE PRESIDENT
A RACIST WITH THE TRAVEL BAN.
THEY ACCUSED THE PRESENT,
FOX NEWS, YOURS TRULY, THIS
PROGRAM, NOT TAKING THE VIRUS
SERIOUSLY ENOUGH.
THEY WERE GIVEN ALL THE EVIDENCE
TO THE CONTRARY.
MORE DETAILS, LET’S LOOK AT OUR
CONFERENCE OF TIMELINE.
"NEW YORK TIMES" JANUARY 8TH,
THEY REPORTED "THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT THE NEW VIRUS IS
READILY SPREAD BY HUMANS.
OKAY.
KEEP IN MIND IN JANUARY, CHINA
WAS INVOLVED IN A MASSIVE
COVER-UP IN THE INFORMATION THAT
WE WERE GETTING WAS FULL OF
LIES, COMPLETELY INACCURATE.
JANUARY 14TH, WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, REMEMBER THEM?
WE PAY THOSE BILLS.
CHINESE AUTHORITIES HAVE FOUND
NO CLEAR EVIDENCE OF HUMAN TO
HUMAN TRANSMISSION.
JANUARY 15TH, COVID-19 -- WELL,
REMEMBER IT WASN’T EVEN ON
NANCY PELOSI’S RADAR.
TOP DEMOCRAT IN THE COUNTRY IS
ALL SMILES.
SHE IS DOING THE SELFIES, GIVING
AWAY TENS, SIGNING OFF ON HER
BIG IMPEACHMENT STUNT WITH
COMMEMORATIVE EVERYTHING.
BUT ONLY A WEEK LATER,
JANUARY 21ST, THE FIRST CASE,
JANUARY 21ST, THE FIRST CASE OF
CORONAVIRUS IN THE U.S.
ON THAT VERY SAME DAY, EVEN
AMERICA’S TOP EXPERT, WHO I HAVE
A TON OF RESPECT FOR, HAS
SPENT -- HE HAS SAVED LIVES ALL
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER.
HE DIDN’T UNDERSTAND IT EITHER,
HE WAS BEING LIED TO TOO.
DR. FAUCI SAID THIS IS NOT A
MAJOR THREAT TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE UNITED STATES.
JANUARY 26, FAUCI REITERATED THE
VIRUS IS "VERY, VERY LOW RISK TO
THE UNITED STATES.
I’M NOT ATTACKING DR. FAUCI.
HE WAS WORKING WITH CHINESE LIES
AS SPREAD BY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
THEN OF COURSE I HAD HIM ON MY
SHOW ON JANUARY 27, 2 DAYS LATER
LATER.
PEOPLE LIKE BUZZFEED PUBLISHING
A HEADLINE, DON’T WORRY ABOUT
THE CORONAVIRUS, WORRY ABOUT THE
FLU.
CNN WAS SAYING THAT ON MARCH THE
THAT.
JANUARY 31ST, BOX TWEETED IS
THIS GOING TO BE DEADLY
PANDEMIC?
NO.
SAME DAY, "WASHINGTON POST"
PUBLISHED A PIECE WITH THE
HEADLINE "HOW OUR BRAINS MAKE
CORONAVIRUS SEEM SCARIER THAN IT
IS."
NOW THE PRESIDENT, HE DOESN’T
SEEK THE ADVICE THANKFULLY FROM
"WASHINGTON POST," THE MEDIA
MOB, BOX, ANY OF THEM.
BECAUSE TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
CASE EMERGED IN THIS COUNTRY,
YOUR PRESIDENT EMMA PRESIDENT
DONALD J. TRUMP MADE THE BOLDEST
DECISION TO BAN TRAVEL TO AND
FROM CHINA.
HE DECLARED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
IT IS INCALCULABLE --
INCALCULABLE -- HOW MANY UNTOLD
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS DID NOT
CONTRACT THIS DISEASE AND UNTOLD
AMERICAN LIVES WERE SAVED.
BY THE WAY, HE GOT NOTHING BUT
CRITICISM, RACISM, XENOPHOBIA,
FEARMONGERING, HYSTERIA.
THIS DECISIVE ACTION THOUGH, TEN
DAYS AFTER THE FIRST CASE, IT
BOUGHT US TIME, IT SAVED US FROM
AN IMMEASURABLE AMOUNT OF
SUFFERING.
THE MOB IN THE MEDIA, THEY WERE
OUTRAGED.
FAKE NEWS CNN ACCUSING THE
PRESIDENT OF USING THE
CORONAVIRUS TO SPREAD FEAR AND
RACISM AND XENOPHOBIA.
TOLD YOU THEY ARE JUST ECHOING
QUID PRO QUO JOE.
WASHINGTON POST, EARLY FEBRUARY,
THERE HEADLINE WAS THIS, "WHY WE
SHOULD BE WARY OF AN AGGRESSIVE
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE TO
CORONAVIRUS.
FEBRUARY 4TH, WHAT WAS
NANCY PELOSI DOING?
OR MEMBER SHE WAS DOING A
LITTLE -- SHE COULD HAVE A
PUBLIC, WELL, TEMPER TANTRUM,
PREORDAINED OF COURSE, BUT THE
PRESIDENT’S STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS IT -- THE CAMERAS -- BY
THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT THAT
NIGHT WAS TALKING ABOUT
COVID-19.
SHE WAS BUSY RIPPING.
AND GET THIS, FEBRUARY 5TH, YOUR
BELOVED "NEW YORK TIMES," THE
SAME PAPER ACCUSING ME OF
DOWNPLAYING THE VIRUS WHEN JUST
THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE, AND I WILL
PROVE IT, RAN THIS HEADLINE.
WHO SAYS IT’S NOT SAFE TO TRAVEL
TO CHINA?
"NEW YORK TIMES" WAS ADVISING
YOU TO GO OVER TO CHINA.
THAT WAS DUMB.
THE CORONAVIRUS TRAVEL BAN IS
UNJUST, THEY SAID, IT DOESN’T
WORK ANYWAY.
TWO SEPARATE DEMOCRATIC DEBATES
IN FEBRUARY, NOT ONE CANDIDATE
ON STAGE MENTIONED THE
CORONAVIRUS.
NOT ONE.
MEANWHILE, NEW YORK CITY’S
HEALTH COMMISSIONER WAS ALSO
DOWNPLAYING THE THREAT OF THE
VIRUS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE RISK TO NEW YORKERS FOR
CORONAVIRUS IS LOW AND THAT OUR
PREPAREDNESS AS A CITY IS VERY
HIGH.
THERE IS NO REASON NOT TO TAKE
THE SUBWAY, NOT TO TAKE THE BUS,
NOT TO GO OUT TO YOUR FAVORITE
RESTAURANT.
>> Sean: NOW, LET’S
FAST-FORWARD TO FEBRUARY 24TH.
REMEMBER, TRUMP PUT THE TRAVEL
BAN IN EFFECT A MONTH EARLIER.
OKAY, WE’RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
THERE’S NANCY PELOSI SHOWING UP,
PUBLICITY STUNT, CROWDED
STREETS, SAN FRANCISCO’S
CHINATOWN, HUGGING, SHAKING
HANDS WITH HER SUPPORTERS AND
ENCOURAGING EVERYONE TO GO AND
SOCIALLY UNDISTANCE.
FEBRUARY 26, THE TIMES RAN
ANOTHER UNHINGED OP-ED ENTITLED
"LET’S CALL IT FROM VIRUS."
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THAT
DOESN’T LIKE ME.
IF YOU’RE FEELING AWFUL, YOU
KNOW WHO TO BLAME.
IN MARCH, FAKE NEWS CNN SAID
THAT CALLING THE CORONAVIRUS
WUHAN OR CHINA CORONAVIRUS WAS
RACIST.
EVEN THOUGH FAKE NEWS ACOSTA
HIMSELF USED THE EXACT SAME
TERMINOLOGY IN JANUARY.
ON MARCH THE 2ND, THERE’S THE
MAYOR OF NEW YORK, CONRAD
DE BLASIO ENCOURAGING
NEW YORKERS TO GO OUT ON THE TOW
TO CATCH A FLIGHT.
SAME DAY, CORONER CUOMO SAYS
EXCUSE OUR ARROGANCE, BUT THIS
DISEASE WILL NOT BE AS BAD IN NE
OTHER COUNTRIES.
IT WAS WORSE, AND ON
MARCH THE 4TH, FAKE NEWS CNN
ANDERSON COOPER, HERE’S WHAT HE
HAD TO SAY ABOUT THE VIRUS.
LET’S PAY ATTENTION TO HIS
TIMELINE.
>> HALF OF THE PEOPLE IN AMERICA
DO NOT GET A FLU SHOT HAD THE
FLU RIGHT NOW IS FAR DEADLIER SO
IF YOU’RE FREAKED OUT AT ALL
ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS, YOU
SHOULD BE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FLU AND YOU CAN ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND GET A
FLU SHOT.
>> Sean: THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND ARE THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND.
THEY DID CHANGE AT DIFFERENT
TIMES.
IT WOULD HAVE TO CONCEDE EVEN
WITH DR. FAUCI, FEBRUARY --
JANUARY -- FEBRUARY 29TH AND THE
RISK IS SO LOW.
MARCH 9TH, DR. FAUCI EVEN SEVER
HOW THE PEOPLE THAT CAN STILL GO
ON A CRUISE SHIP, BUT THAT
STATEMENT NEVER MADE IT INTO
THIS WEEKEND’S "NEW YORK TIMES"
HIT PIECE AGAINST THIS PROGRAM.
THEY HATE ALL THINGS FROM, ALL
THINGS CONSERVATIVE, AND THEY
HATE SEAN HANNITY, LIKES
DONALD TRUMP AND SAYS ON RADIO
AND TV.
NEITHER DID THEY WATCH MY TIME
ON, WHICH, BY THE WAY, I SPENT
AN ENTIRE HOUR GOING OVER WITH
ONE OF THEIR TOP-NOTCH FAKES
NEWS REPORTERS AND IT’S BEEN
POSTED ON Hannity.com I
BELIEVE SINCE MARCH THE 18TH.
WE HAD DR. FAUCI ON THIS PROGRAM
AS EARLY AS JANUARY 27TH
DISCUSSING THE SERIOUS NATURE OF
THE VIRUS.
THE NEXT DAY I TALKED TO A PANEL
OF DOCTORS.
FEBRUARY 10TH I HAD DR. FAUCI
BACK ON TO TALK ABOUT WHAT ABOUT
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE A SYMPTOM
ATTIC AND THE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE.
IT’S ALL THERE, YOU CAN SEE IT
ALL, Hannity.com, AT
SEAN HANNITY TWITTER.
WITH GOT IT ALL THEIR IMPRINTS,
FOR ALL OF YOU LIARS, ALL OF YOU
INVOLVES AND SMEARS, SLANDER,
BESMIRCH ME.
ALL OF YOUR CHARACTER
ASSESSMENTS, YOU CAN ALL READ,
MIGHT HAVE TO LEARN SOMETHING.
WE PRAISE THE PRESIDENT’S BOLD
ACTION TO HALT TRAVEL FROM
CHINA.
THAT WAS A GAME CHANGER.
THIS IS BEEN THE BIGGEST MEDICAL
MOBILIZATION IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
OKAY, EVERYONE THAT NEEDED A
VENTILATOR GOT A VENTILATOR.
NOT BECAUSE ANY STATE HAD ANY OF
THEM.
HOSPITALS WERE BUILT IN UNDER A
WEEK, INCLUDING THE
JAVITS CENTER.
THE NAVY SHIPS WERE SENT.
THE VENTILATORS WERE SENT.
OF THE MASKS, THE GOWNS, THE
GLOVES, THE RESPIRATORS, ALL
SENT.
RECORD TIME.
IT NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT,
BITES WERE SAVED.
NONE OF THAT MADE IT INTO THE
FAKE NEWS, NEW YORK’S LIBEL
SLANDER TIMES ARTICLE.
THAT’S BECAUSE THE SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS WHO WORK THERE, THEY
ARE NOT INTERESTED IN THE TRUTH.
THAT IS A FACT.
INSTEAD, THEY CARE ABOUT
BLUDGEONING ENEMIES.
FOR THEM, ENEMY NUMBER ONE IS
NOT ME, THAT WOULD BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ENEMY NUMBER TWO IS ANYBODY AND
EVERYBODY, INCLUDING VOTERS THAT
SUPPORT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
"NEW YORK TIMES" IS NOT ALONE.
LOOK AT HOW FAKE NEWS CNN AND,
YES, CONSPIRACY TELEVISION
BOSWELL RACHEL MADDOW AT MS AT
DNC, COVERED THIS SERIOUS VIRUS
OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS.
TAKE A LOOK IN THE MIDDLE OF A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS SOUNDING
VERY BAGHDAD BOB-LIKE IN THE WAY
THAT HE’S ASSIGNING BLAME TO
EVERYBODY BUT HIMSELF.
>> THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE WHO WILL DIE IN THE
COUNTRY OR SOME OF THEM HAVE
ALREADY DIED, MORE ARE STILL
GOING TO DIE BECAUSE OF
DONALD TRUMP’S INCOMPETENT --
>> HERE WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
IS EXPLOITING A NATIONAL CRISIS
TO MOVE FORWARD HIS OWN AGENDA,
HIS OWN REVENGE, HIS OWN PROFIT.
A PRESIDENT DETERMINED TO
REWRITE THE HISTORY OF HIS EARLY
AND REPREHENSIBLE HE
IRRESPONSIBLE RESPONSE TO THIS
VIRUS.
>> HE’S STILL ACTING RECKLESS
AND ONBOARD.
>> HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, WE
ARE STILL NOT DOING WHAT WE NEED
TO DO TO FIGHT THIS DEADLY VIRUS
BECAUSE OF A COMPLETE LACK OF
LEADERSHIP.
>> DO YOU THINK IS ALREADY -- DO
YOU THINK THERE IS BLOOD ON THE
PRESIDENT’S HANDS CONSIDERING
THE SLOW RESPONSE?
>> Sean: WOW, FOR THE PEOPLE
YOU JUST SAW THIS VIRUS, YEP,
UNFORTUNATELY THEY POLITICIZED
IT PRETTY EARLY ON.
ONE MORE OPPORTUNITY, THEY GOT
EVERYTHING ELSE WRONG ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, RUSSIA, UKRAINE,
IMPEACHMENT, NEVER INVESTIGATED